ja wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung
heute geht es um die ethik der
computerspiele
wir haben ein quiz gemacht
auffi lowcost können sie sich auch mal
anschauen zum thema ethik der
digitalität
aber jetzt geht es um die leitfragen
also was sind überhaupt computerspiele
aus philosophischer perspektive
diese frage müssen wir uns zuerst
stellen bevor wir überhaupt über die
ethik der computerspiele sprechen können
wie können wir computerspiele ethisch
bewerten
dass es dann die entscheidende frage
inwiefern sind computerspiele bloße
fiktionen inwiefern simulation und
inwiefern virtuelle realitäten das soll
die fragen seien ich möchte jetzt noch
hinweisen auf eine wie ich finde
spannende sendung dieses podcast des
screens
in der ich auch mitgemacht habt da ging
es um ethik und moral im games oben
rechts mache ich den link zu dieser
sitze reihen des podcast darüber
diskutiert könnte den ein oder anderen
von ihnen interessieren
jetzt möchte ich ein bisschen was
evolution der computerspiele sagen denn
computerspiele haben sich in den letzten
50 jahren erst entwickelt davor gab es
die schlicht und einfach noch nicht gibt
es vielleicht schon seit den 50ern 60ern
aber wann genau bis jetzt auch nicht so
entscheidend entscheidend ist einfach
dass sie wissen ist ein neueres phänomen
dieses spiel kennen sie alle das ist
einer der urväter uhr mütter das konnte
wieder spielt dass es das spiel
kostenlose 72 dieser version wenn ich
jetzt diese evolution die entwicklung
des computerspiels ihn darstelle
überlegen sie immer mal in niefern ist
dieses computerspiel ethisch
problematisch ja inwiefern ist dieses
computerspiel oder inwiefern könnte es
politisch problematisch sein
sie werden sehen mit dem ersten spielen
stellt sich seine problematik erst mal
noch gar nicht unabhängig davon dass
natürlich immer sagen kann eine person
die die ganze zeit nichts anderes macht
als dieses spiel zu spielen ja die hat
irgendwelche probleme sicherlich die
bekommen probleme aber das ist ja
eigentlich mit allem so ich kann auch
die ganze zeit nur irgendwelche romane
lesen ja man könnte sagen die augen
werden schlecht gut aber auch beim lesen
werden die augen vielleicht irgendwann
schlägt also da ist nicht viel
kritisches
problematisches potenzial angelegten
diesen spielen ist ein ganz simples
spiel was wird hier dargestellt was wird
hier simuliert muss man sich fragen ja
gut es ist ein ball ein ein simulierter
ball ob sie ein virtueller balles muss
man sich noch fragen der hier eben oder
ein punkt der vielleicht etwas von einem
ball hat der eine ballphysik
simuliert warum weil er abprallte und
der sollen hier irgendwie gegen
gespiegelte seiner tennis sein ein
simuliertes reduzierte stents jahren
hier ist ein netz die grenze in der
mitte des spielfelds und wenn der ball
daraus geht dann hat die andere partei
ein punkt reicht dieses spiel konnte man
schon geringe computer spielen also hier
waren eine gewisse künstliche
intelligenz schon enthalten natürlich
konnte man das auch zu zweit spielen
nächstes spiel commander keen
aus dem jahr also 290 ich habe es noch
spielt auch gerade in dieser zeit
also ich habe es wirklich kennengelernt
also ungefähr erschienen ist und
es ist jetzt eine sequenz dies immer
wieder holt jetzt überlegen sie mal hier
was hat sich hier verändert erstens das
spiel sieht wesentlich realistischer aus
natürlich immer noch unter einschränkung
warum es ist der comic haft gestaltet
hat es ist comic heft und die figuren
sind ja überzeichnet ja die sind ganz
klar als
fiktive wesen er sich sie haben es hier
mit fiktiven identitäten zu tun eine
seltsame schnecke und hier ist ein
hüpfball der ist er freundlich die
schnecke hingegen die ist nicht so
freundlich die verzieht den mund
deswegen wird sie auch von dieser figur
hier dass der commander keen können sie
spielen von dieser figur wird diese
schnecke erschossen jetzt kann man sich
fragen was ist daran ethisch
problematisch ja
fängt schon an hier haben sie eine
simulierte waffe und sie schießen zwei
wesen ja nicht tot aber sie sind
da sag ich mal also die frage was ist
hier ethisch problematische fängt schon
an kann er wird gewalt dargestellt wenn
auch in diesem spiel auf eine sehr
sympathisch nicht brutale weise aber
hier fängt schon an
irgendwie ethisch relevanten es geht
weiter mit einem spiel was die sind
gedanken des schießens nochmal
radikalisiert das ist wolfenstein 3d das
war lange zeit indiziert in deutschland
hatte verfassungsfeindliche symbole
beinhaltet hakenkreuzes handelt aber
nicht von einem nationalsozialistischen
pokert protagonisten diese figur diese
hier spielen die soll gerade gegen die
nazis kämpfen auf dem boden liegt ein
toter nazi und dieses spiel war dennoch
initiiert worden warum in dieser zeit
weil es eben für die damalige zeit auch
heute immer noch ein bisschen
authentischer also die simulation ist
hier fortgeschritten es ist nicht mehr
als 2 disc olavi dass es spielt das
wetter vorgesehen commander keen sind es
ist eine 3d spielen zumindest ein
rudimentäres 3d spiel aus der
ich-perspektive wo sie aus ich
perspektive mit einer vorgehaltenen
waffe andere person töten
simuliert natürlich nicht in
wirklichkeit ja jetzt ist die frage
hängt es davon ab wen oder was sie da
ein töten es handelt sich ja um eine
böse macht insofern könnte man sagen es
ist doch gerechtfertigt da aber die
gewaltdarstellung waren teilweise recht
explizit es gab sogar wiederholung
szenen wenn man and gegner besiegt hatte
wo die animation eben sehr explizit war
auch wenn er sich da jetzt um
nationalsozialisten handelte die
gewaltdarstellung war da und hier gibt
es eine vorwurf gewaltverherrlichende
spiele hier sieht man gleich das
ethische problem gewalt fertig ja diese
technik dieses vorherigen spiels ist die
sogenannte
rating engine die von einem standpunkt
ausgeht und dann ganz verschiedene
linien wirft an die gegenüberliegenden
winde und so ergibt sich ein simulierter
dreidimensionaler raum also die objekte
die weiter zurück sind die erscheinen
kleiner so wie es auch in unserer 3d
perspektive ist die ebenen die näher
sind wie diese blaue die erscheinen
größer und wenn natürlich die sich
erstrecken auf die seite dann braucht er
strahlt von mir länger also wird kleiner
und so erhalten sie eine simulierte 3d
perspektive
aus der ich perspektive hat es ist also
eine ganz spannende technik die dahinter
steht auf die möchte nicht mehr eingehen
ich nach oben rechts und links zu einem
anderen vorlesung von mir da ging es um
die ästhetik der computerspiele bot das
vielleicht noch ein bisschen zentrale
ist technik fast in ganz interessant ja
jetzt haben wir noch einen spielen
nämlich quake
1969 der erste teil hier sehen sie ihr
wird es jetzt noch noch realistischer
sie haben es hier mit lichteffekten zu
tun ist auch eine kurze sequenz die
waffen animation ist viel exakter auch
wenn es hier nur ein monster ist im
krieg haben sie es auch mit anderen
figuren zu tun die zwar immer noch
monster sind aber menschlichen personen
eher ähneln und hier kann man sich
natürlich fragen ist das moralisch
vertretbar auf diese person zu schießen
es gibt natürlich noch ganz andere
waffen das ist übrigens eine neue liga
wird mit nägeln geschossen auch wenn es
nur ein monster ist und die neueste
grafik generation dass es die an real
engine 5 die gibt's halt paar wenigen
jahren ist auch frei zugänglich
die hat wie sie hier sehen ganz
beeindruckend licht und schatteneffekte
das ist das sogenannte rating also nicht
mehr raytracing casting hier gibt es
wirklich perfekt nahezu perfekt
simulierte
lichtquellen und schattenwürfe und das
wie sie alle wissen diese
lichtverhältnisse machen sehr viel aus
auch in puncto plastizität also es wird
immer realistischer das ist denke ich
eine ganz klare entwicklung
der computer spiele grafik gerede über
grafische simulationen natürlich spielt
auch der toner rolle ist immer noch die
frage was sonst noch simulierten aber es
geht vor allem um die grafische
simulation und sie können sich denken
mehr etwas grafisch simuliert wird umso
authentischer drittes und es könnte
dementsprechend auch wenn ethisch
problematisch ist auf eine solche
realistische weise simuliert wird ja
umso problematischer erscheinen darüber
müssen wir aber heute jetzt sprechen das
war eine kurze
evolutionsgeschichte des computerspiels
und jetzt geht es aber um die frage was
eigentlich computerspiele sind
hier gibt es verschiedene kandidaten man
könnte sagen ist doch ganz einfach
computerspiele sind spiele sagt doch
schon der titel
könnte aber auch sagen computerspiele
sind neue medien gut auch spiele können
medien seien aber die frage was uns
eigentlich neue medien man könnte aber
auch sagen nun computerspiele sind
fiktionen das sind erzählungen die
nichts mit unserer realität zu tun haben
siehe dieses spiel kommt ja commander
keen gibt es schnecken komische
schnecken da gibt es komische hüpfbälle
die lebendig sind das sind ganz klar
fantasien fiktionen man könnte aber auch
sagen das sind simulationen da bewegt
sich doch eine schnecke im spiel der
wird doch eine schnecke vielleicht
fingiert weil sie etwas anders aussieht
und weise in wirklichkeit gibt es nicht
so große schnecken und schnecken sind
auch nicht so böse wie diese schnecke
dort in diesem spiel und schnecken
werden auch nicht bewusstlos wenn man
auf sie schießt das sind also fiktive
stecken aber sie sind simuliert weil sie
bewegen sich wenn sie ende dem
wirklichen schnecken gewesen zu fordern
ist eine simulierte computerspiel
schnecke und dann gibt es aber auch noch
die möglichkeit zu sagen sind virtuelle
realität also wie ihr interagieren mit
objekten und diese objekte mit dem wir
im computerspiel interagieren die sind
doch irgendwie auch wirklich sind
vielleicht simulation aber können wir
wirklich mit dem interagieren
deswegen sind die virtuelle realität ja
alle diese möglichkeiten diese fünf
antworten werden in der gegenwärtigen
debatte vertreten und es ist noch
keineswegs klar was hier sich als
eigentlicher kandidat besonders
herausstellt haben ja jetzt müssen wir
mal erst mal auf die erster kandidat
einige nämlich auf das spiel
anthropologie des spiels von friedrich
schiller stammt der satz der mensch
spielt nur wo er in voller bedeutung des
wortes mensch ist und er ist nur da ganz
mensch wo er spielt
ja dass ein
auszug aus den briefen über die
ästhetische erziehung des menschen sie
sehen schon es geht um eine ästhetische
erziehung des menschen also das spiel
mit ihrem kontext der ist tätig also der
schönheit aber auch der bildung
betrachtet ja jetzt könnte man natürlich
denken schiller hatte hier keine
computerspiele im kopf er konnte so was
sicherlich gar nicht antizipieren dass
es so etwas 200 jahre nach seinem tod
mal geben würde er sich andere spiele
hier kann man sich jetzt verschiedene
spielen vorstellen man kann sich jetzt
vor spielen vorstellen theater spiele wo
man eine rolle spielt dann spiel ein
klee oder man kann sich aber auch ein
game oder gambling wie es im englischen
heißt für spielen also ein kartenspiel
oder ein gesellschaftsspiel oder ein
kinderspiel ich denke es ist ganz egal
was wir uns von der vorstellung es geht
einfach um das spiel und das spiel ist
etwas was wir erst mal nicht
der wirklichkeit wie wir sie gewöhnlich
kennen zu folgen hat im spiel sind wir
frei das ist ein scheiben spielzeug für
frei im spiel können wir uns selbst auch
experimentell
austesten und wir können im spiel etwas
regieren wir können zu fantasieren
kreativität
entwickeln lassen auch im verhältnis zu
anderen menschen denken sie daran wie
kinder spielen kindern werden sie ganz
eigene welten in dem eigene gesetze
gelten wenn man es zu zweit spielt dann
wird es spannend ob jemand die regeln
bricht und wann wieder die wirklich
realität beginnt aber sie sehen spielen
ist ein abschied aus didaktischen
psychologischen gründen extrem wichtig
nicht nur in der kindheit auch wir
erwachsenen menschen spielen die ganze
zeit es gibt dieses phänomen des gaming
fiction also der verspätung sag ich
jetzt mal von verschiedenen inhalten ist
macht die sache leichter macht sie
freier und ist bringt die sache auf
unter umständen nähern uns heran aus
didaktischer sichtlich das spiel ist
etwas was lebens wirkliche bedeutung hat
was in unseren alltag immer wieder
vorkommt in ganz verschiedenen bereich
ja jetzt können wir auf die
anthropologie des spiels nochmal ein
bisschen näher eingehen das hatte ich
schon gesagt ihm spielen wirft sich der
menschen seiner freiheit im spiel
experimentiert der mensch mit
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit eben weil
im spiel auch fiktionen möglich sind
jetzt kann man sich fragen stellen
computerspiele eine neue form von
spieldauer
gab es solche spiele früher noch nicht
ich würde sagen ja und zwar deswegen
weil die technik dahinter uns einfach
viele andere dinge ermöglicht und durch
das internet eben auch noch eine ganze
neue reibungslose weise der vernetzung
erlaubt man jetzt kann man sich fragen
worin besteht denn dann die besonderheit
von computerspielen im gegensatz etwa zu
brettspielen wie schach worin besteht
der unterschied habe unterschied besteht
darin dass schach
grenzen hat schon hat möglichkeiten aber
auch ganz starke grenzen die grenzen
fangen damit an dass das spielfeld
begrenzt ist beschränkt ist die grenzen
fangen damit an dass es ganz klare
regeln gibt die streng eingehalten
werden müssen also es hat nicht
besonders viele flexibilität immer noch
genug für
professionelle spielerinnen und spieler
ganz klar varianten eröffnung und so
weiter aber ist ist beschränkt und
vielleicht noch ganz entscheidend es ist
eben nicht reibungslos damit meine ich
bestens doch noch man kann zwar schon im
kopf spielen ohne die figuren aber
es hat nicht diese flexibilität die
computerspiele erlauben
flexibilität meint jetzt ganz
verschiedene 7 die möglichkeit zu
spielen mit etwas zu spielen aber auch
die reibungslose ich kai timm
simulierten raum dank der digitalen
technik dank der erweiterbarkeit der
digitalen technik dank der vernetztheit
dank der integration von künstlicher
intelligenz des computerspiele ist ein
viel offeneres und viel flexibleres
medium als es das schachspiel ist und
schafft würde ich nicht als ein medium
ansehen computerspiele hingegen schon
einer gewissen
sind computerspiele dann nur spiegel
oder sind sie viel mehr als das sehr gut
diese frage kann man sich auch bei
stellen es gibt professionelle im
schachspielerin spieler die damit ihr
geld machen da die gibt es überall auch
jetzt im internet dann wird es besonders
spannend bis schach im medium des
computerspiels realisiert wird
er handelt es sich dann noch ein
wirkliches schach oder nur um
simuliertes schaaf auch nicht bange
frage ich glaube aber computerspiele
sind mehr als nur spiele und warum das
werden wir sehen weil sie eben auch von
ethische problematik sein können schach
kann nicht von ethische problematik sein
würde ich behaupten und das
unterscheidet eben auch schaffen anderen
computerspielen nur weil im schachspiel
nicht groß simuliert wird sondern eben
nur gespielt oder regeln gefolgt wird
auf eine kreative weiß in
computerspielen tritt noch viel mehr der
fiktive aspekt hinzu der simulation der
kreativen aber natürlich das schachspiel
irgendwas simulieren bis hat man
natürlich ein bauer eine dame ein läufer
einspringer irgendwie auch simuliert
wird wenn auch nur ganz rudimentär man
kann es darin sehen die dame ist eben
die königin sozusagen die kann sehr viel
die hat viel macht und diese macht wird
repräsentiert oder vielleicht simuliert
durch die verschiedenen suchoptionen der
bauer hingegen ist in seinem macht ganz
klein wird auch durch die größe
symbolisiert es geht auch um
symbolisierung simulation und er hat nur
einen geringen bewegungsradius na also
es wird schon irgendwie simuliert aber
doch auf eine gericht beschränkte weise
recht erstarrte weiß ja was sind
computerspiele dann wenn sie nicht nur
spiele sind neue medien hatte ich schon
gesagt das wort medium komplett einisch
mitte und bedeutet soviel wie
vermittlung sonst hat das kann man sich
fragen vermitteln computerspiele etwas
vermitteln sie informationen wie es
zeitungen tun wie es mich andere medien
tun wie lehrbücher ich glaube nicht
inwiefern vermitteln sie überhaupt etwas
zwischen wem wird hier der inhalt des
computerspiels an die spielerin
vermittelt seltsam glaube ich nicht also
computerspieler sind von medien wie viel
man zeitungen und bücher verschieden da
sie nicht nur passiv rezitiert und
konsumiert sondern aktiv gespielt werden
dass der entscheidende unterschied
häufig werden computerspiele nur als
kombi medien abgetan als wären es
inhalt die wir allein passiv rezipieren
so wird das manchmal weil wir natürlich
vor dem monitor recht regungslos sitzt
selbst wenn wir vor einer spielekonsole
sitzen die ja nur auf das spiel
konzentriert ist anders als der computer
der natürlich für viele andere zwecke
noch nützlich ist selbst dann wenn der
fahrer kommt spiele konsole sitzen wirkt
es so als würden wir nur konsumieren
warum wirkt das so weil wir nur ein paar
tasten drücken also unsere bewegung sind
ganz minimal
der arbeiten der debatten des
steuerkreuzes riecht schon vollziehen
wir eine gewalt bedeutsame simulierte
handlung und computerspiele es wird
natürlich auf die betrachterinnen und
den betrachter so als würden uns nur
berieseln lassen es aber nicht so in
computerspielen sind wir viel aktiver
als wir es beim konsum von anderen
medien sind deswegen glaube ich sollten
der computerspiele nicht nur als mädchen
als neue medien verstehen spielen ist
ein komplexes wirklichkeit verhältnis
wir entwerfen etwas selbst wir
realisieren unseren charakter selbst im
spiel ist hängt damit an welchen avatar
welches spiels die jäger einen tag legen
welche strategien entwickeln und so
weiter das geht alles bei der rezeption
von filmen zeitungen büchern zu
ja jetzt kann man sich fragen sind
computerspiele dann fiktionen ja das
glaube ich schon ihr computer spielen
werden wir mit fiktiven gehalten
konfrontiert und übernehmen auch fiktive
rollen es fängt an mit pong mit diesem
ersten spiel was hier gezeigt hatte ja
das sind sie in eine fiktive gierten ja
was sind sie da überhaupt
sind sie ein schläger in einem
tennisspiel in einem fußballspiel
irgendwas seltsam so was gibt's gar
nicht aber sie ahnen was es ist sie
sehen dahinter noch irgendwie ein
wirklichkeit bezug aber es hat sich
davon gelöst noch klarer ist es bei
computer commander team commander keen
könnte wie so ein traum sein entspanntes
die trauben ja ein netter freundlicher
fand dass sie trauen dem
schnecken laufen groß sind dem schnecken
böse sind in dem hüpfende bälle
freundlich sind in dem man bei schießen
kann aber das sind ja nur betäubt wir
töten sie nicht es fließt kein blut und
so weiter das ist eine ganz klare
fiktion so was könnte aus dem roman
stand der unterschied ist nur im roman
werden sie mit diesen ganzen
geschehnissen konfrontiert die laufen
vor ihrem geistigen auge ab und die
haben sie selbst nicht erzeugt sie
müssen sicherlich das was im roman steht
vor ihrem geistigen auge
rekonstruieren erschaffen lassen
erzeugen darin besteht ihre aktive
haltung also auch wenn man etwas
rezitiert ein roman ist mir nicht nur
passiv man muss natürlich in seiner
phantasie erzeugen vor dem geistigen
auge aber sie erzeugen nicht den gang
der handlung zu einem sie erzeugen nur
was schon vorbestimmt ist das lassen sie
in von der geistigen auge entstehen aber
der bauplan gewissermaßen der wirtin
vorgegeben und so ist es nicht bei
computerspielen computerspielen da
verändern sie die struktur sie haben
natürlich ausdruck von vorgegeben
gewisse settings wie zb diesen
hintergrund dieser welt was sie in
dieser welt machen ob sie diese schnecke
schießen oder nicht ob sie auf diesen
ball hüpfte und mit diesen ball durch
die ganze welt hüpfen das geht nämlich
bei kann man mag ihn das bleibt ihnen in
ihrer kreativität selbst verlassen sind
wesentlich aktiver natürlich übernehmen
sind effektive rolle denken sie allein
an diesen schläger balkon sind sie links
oder rechts das ist schon eine gewisse
rolle des commander keen wird es
deutlicher der sind sie dieser kleiner
junge der geflohen ist auf einem
planeten da gibt es eine riesen
geschichte dahinter können sie mal
googeln der hat einen helm auf und der
pistole der hat auch anspringen stock
und dem springen diese rolle übernehmen
sie die rolle übernehmen sie auch in
wolfenstein das sind sie auch ein
bestimmter protagonist auch in quake
unserer anzufordern das scheint etwas
typisches für computerspiele zahl in
computerspielen bekommen wir eine
geschichte erzählt es gibt dieses
hintergrund settings aber wir schreiben
die geschichte individuelle fort das
habe ich gerade beschrieben indem wir
uns ganz individuellen verhalten zu den
vorgegebenen fiktiven
konstanten wir machen und sind
computerspielen die fiktion also zu
eigen wir
produzieren sie nicht nur wie konz
rekonstruieren sie nicht nur in unserer
phantasie wie bei filmen computerspielen
oder noch mahnen bei filmen ist es so
dass wir selbst die visuellen eindrücke
alle schon geliefert bekommt die müssen
wir gar nicht mehr erzeugen wie bei
roman wir bestimmt aber in
computerspielen interaktiv selbst wie
die geschichte ausgeht dass das
entscheidende wir in den allermeisten
spielen sicherlich gibt es ein
vorgefertigtes ziel aber wie wir zu dem
ziel kommen das bleibt uns offen und die
neueren computerspiele flexibilisieren
auch immer diese story weil wir hier
ganz verschiedene enden der geschichte
selbst bestimmen kann das macht
natürlich das spiel noch viel autonome
selbst bestimmt habe wir sind selbst ihr
reduziere teile des computerspiels das
ist entscheidend wie er der spieler die
spielerin wird selbst zum teil des
computerspiels das computerspiel ist
ohne uns selbst gar nicht zu denken
und das ist glaube ich anders als bei
filmen und büchern hörbüchern könnte man
sie noch drüber streiten
bei filmen scheint es mit überhaupt
nicht notwendig zu sein bei
computerspielen sehr wichtig ein
computerspiel ohne spieler spielerin ist
kein computer spielen das heißt wir
werden selbst integriert und zwar
integral also ihr reduziere
sind wir teil computerspiele gibt es nur
wenn sie gespielt wird und sie hängen
davon ab von wem und wie sie gespielt
werden und darin unterscheiden sich
computerspiele von film und roman dh in
computerspielen wird uns so
individualität viel eher einbezogen
damit eben auch unsere freiheit und zu
entscheiden und zu handeln auch wenn es
natürlich keine wirklichen handlungen 10
wirklichen welt und das wird uns jetzt
neben auf die frage nach der ethischen
bedeutung direkt zurück wir müssen aber
noch eine frage klären nämlich die frage
ob computerspiele nicht auch als
simulation adäquat verstanden werden
soll nämlich in computerspielen geht es
nicht nur um fiktionen
sind auch in simulationen also das habe
ich schon gesagt wir simulieren zum
beispiel flugzeuge den microsoft flight
simulator ist ein sehr realistischer
simulator also simulatoren haben das
immer mit einer gewissen realitätsgrad
zu tun es gibt einen kampf simulator es
gibt ganz verschiedene simulatoren man
könnte jetzt die these vertreten
computerspiele sind nichts anderes als
simulationen das würde ich aber
bestreiten warum weil simulationen immer
die wirklichkeit stimmte bereiche der
wirklichkeit
repräsentieren der flugsimulator eben
ein flugzeug verschiedene typen von
flugzeugen kampf simulator eine
kriegssituation oder eine 2 1 situation
aber wir werden beim genaueren hinsehen
immer finden dass diese computerspiele
dann auch fiktive gehalten beinhalten
wir werden zum beispiel irgendwann sehen
dass wir beim flugsimulator dinge machen
können die wir normalerweise gar nicht
machen können es zeigt ihn ist ein sehr
realistisches simulatoren dass es gar
nicht gehen aber sie können im
flugsimulator können sie mit einem
riesen jet auf einer kleinen kiste
starten das gingen normalerweise das ist
sehen hier fängt schon wieder an fiktiv
zu wehr sie bilden nicht nur die
wirklichkeit nach sind die spiele mit
der wirklichkeit dem sie sich neues zu
sagen durch ihre kreativität ihre
fantasten überlegen und das
computerspiel erlaubt geben solche
kreativen
modifikationen sehr sehr gut wie kaum
ein anderes medium
wir selbst simulieren in computerspielen
reale und fiktive handlungen also ich
will beispiel geben wir simulieren reale
handlung wenn wir zum beispiel mit einem
flugzeug auf einer großen kiste starten
die für das flugzeug geeignet ist dann
simulieren wir reale hat wir starten vom
frankfurter flughafen mit einer boeing
737 oder unter wasser also das passiert
auch in der wirklichkeit und wir
vollziehen das nach wenn auch auf eine
reduzierte weise wie sie nicht alles
genauso perfekt aber
ein ganz bestimmtes visuell auch
akustisch wenn wir uns dann noch in so
einem sessel mit vibration setzen können
wir auch noch diese
stimmungsschwankungen
simulieren also es wird simuliert wir
können aber natürlich auch fiktive
handlungen simulieren wir können so tun
als ob wir
in einem fantasy welt während und dort
mit elfen auf die jagd nach monstern
gehen auch da realisieren wir nicht
fiktiv behandlungen würde ich sagen also
die positiven sachen werde nicht zur
realität und sollen sie werden nur
simuliert es wird so getan als ob das
was in der fiktion wäre möglich also
mein vorschlag also es wird sehr
kompliziert wird das genau vorzustellen
ja das heißt computerspiele existierten
der spannung von simulation und fiktion
wir wollen in computerspielen nicht nur
simulieren das wäre für viele von uns zu
langweilig sage ich mal ganz klar sollen
wir wollen daran auch mit der
wirklichkeit auf fiktive weise spielen
also computerspiele sind nicht nur
spiele zeitvertreib sondern es ist das
spiel mit der wirklichkeit
und jetzt zum schluss noch computerspiel
als virtuelle realitäten alles wir
simulieren nicht nur beim
computerspielen könnte man sagen sind
jetzt sollen auch noch eine realität
geben beispiel online multiplayer spiele
wie world of warcraft oder neuerdings
von metall reisen wo sie mit virtuellen
brillen unterwegs sind was macht das
jetzt zur realität und nicht nur zur
simulation oder fiktion auch wenn diese
momente dahin halten ganz einfach sie
haben es in diesen spielen mit werten zu
tun die objektiv sind und mit
gegenständen objektiven wert haben das
ist lieb einer banknote es gibt in
diesem online multiplayer spielen
bewährungen die sie mit wirklichem geld
bezahlen und die einen wirklichen wert
haben das können sie eintauschen daran
halten sich alle das ist nicht nur eine
fiktion und wirklichkeit
und sie können auch in horizon wird
wirklich verabreden sie können wirklich
etwas gemeinsam tun
nicht nur simulieren sie können zwar
wirklich sich simuliert einem
gemeinsamen essen hingeben essen sie
aber natürlich nicht aber was sie
wirklich machen sie treffen sich sie
sozialisieren sich wirklich in der
virtuellen realität und das ist nicht
nur die simulation ihres gemeinsam
zusammentreffen sondern es passiert
wirklich wenn auch nicht physisch so
dort virtuell und das geld die währung
ist auch wirklich wenn auch nicht
physisch so dort virtuell weil ich
glaube computerspiele haben auch anteile
von virtuellen realitäten aber diese
virtuellen realitäten sind noch sehr
sehr gering und das meiste sind
simulationen und fiktion es entstehen
also virtuelle kulturen die nicht
angemessen durch begriffe wie simulation
fiktion oder illusion charakterisiert
sind vor allem dann wenn wir es mit
multiplayer spielen zu tun haben wo wir
mit anderen personen wird schnell
interagieren stichwort virtueller
handlungsraum das internet also
onlinespiel kulturen sind in meinen
augen virtuelle realität
ja sie sind erzeugung von neuen
realitäten durch die neuen medien
virtuelle realität entwickeln sich und
besitzt ganz entscheidend sukzessiv also
nach und nach aus bloßen simulation und
fiktion wenn die regeln des spiels inter
subjektiv alle von verschiedenen
parteien die beteiligt sind geteilt und
institutionalisiert werden also wenn sie
verfestigt werden wenn sie nicht nur
beliebig da hin und her pendeln sondern
wenn man sich darauf einigt das ist
dasselbe wie mit geld- währungs- sicht
auf einige dann wird das ganze real so
und jetzt haben ein riesentorlauf gehabt
der war aber in meinen augen notwendig
philosophisch um mal überhaupt zu
überlegen was computerspiel alles fahren
können und erst wenn wir uns diese frage
eben verlegt haben können wir angemessen
auf die nächste frage über gehen nämlich
auf die frage nach der ethik der
computerspiele ist das eigentlich
moralisch problematisch oder nicht was
wir da tun was ich da ein computerspiel
vollzieht
also die ethische bewertung von
computerspielen zusammengefasst hängt
davon ab ob wir sie als bloße spiel oder
spielereien als neue medien als bloße
fiktion als bloße simulation oder als
virtuelle realitäten anziehen als bloße
spielerei sicherlich wird es nicht so
problematisch es wird aber dann immer
problematischer wenn man sie als medien
ansieht als fiktion als simulation bei
als realitäten und jetzt möchte ich ein
beispiel geben der computerspiele kann
aus verschiedenen gründen moralisch
problematisch sein sie sind
gewaltverherrlichend und werden deswegen
teilweise indiziert dass er absolut
deutschland ich habe es genannt das
spiel wolfenstein 3d wurde als
deutschland zumindest als
gewaltverherrlichend bezeichnet und
deswegen infiziert also eingezogen
verboten sie können auch deswegen
problematisch sein dass sie andere
menschen diskriminieren dass man also in
computerspielen
simuliert mit anderen menschen die keine
solche klar erkenntlich sind etwas tut
was man nicht tun sollte
klassischerweise mann tötet sie jetzt
stellt sich die frage sind die inhalte
von computerspielen nicht durch das
grundrecht auf freie meinungsäußerung
und die freiheit der kunst gedeckt also
wenn computerspiele kunstwerke sind
dürfte man doch in der kunst alles
mögliche punkt ist nicht die realität
sondern fiktion
ja ich glaube dass computerspiele mehr
sind also nur meinungsäußerungen kunst
merkel sondern wirklichkeit
verhandlungen als in computerspielen
wird nicht nur etwas präsentiert ab
gespielt da hängt nicht nur ein bild
herum wir betrachten ist passiv sowie
computerspielen sind wir involviert da
machen wir selbst fast deswegen ist das
ganze nicht so einfach als kunstwerk
oder als freie meinungsäußerungen
darzustellen weil wir da selbst animiert
werden etwas zu tun je mehr einem
computerspiel unmoralisches detail
hierzu bietet das tue moralisch
problematisch erscheint ich sage jetzt
nicht ist es aber er scheint ist das ist
eben der unterschied
sie könnte das ganz einfach vorstellen
die detaillierte tötungshandlungen
vielleicht auch an unschuldigen
zivilisten im computerspiel
simuliert werden können sich bis zu
jedem beliebigen grad weiter vorstellen
und das was sie da tun eben auch umso
realistischer druck desto unmoralischer
erscheint ist
es gibt hier noch eine kluft zwischen
dem erscheinen und dem sein weil sie
machen es ja nicht wirklich dass der
unterschied sie machen das ja nicht an
wirklichen personen sie machen das ja
nur an wenn auch vielleicht perfekt
simulierte person aber die person die
sie töten oder queren oder was auch
immer in computerspielen die leidet
nicht wirklich auch wenn sie sicherlich
simuliert leiden könnte sie können das
nahezu perfekt simulieren aber die
machen es eben immer noch nicht wirklich
es gibt noch eine ganz kleine kluft
zwischen der perfektesten simulation und
er wirklich kann und deswegen muss man
hier schreiben die mir scheint erscheint
es das soll jetzt aber nicht heißen dass
dieses perfekt simulierte töten eine
unschuldige person nicht unmoralisch ist
warum nicht darauf kommen jetzt gleich
zu sprechen es gibt nämlich gesetzliche
grundlagen das können sie alles
nachlesen auf wikipedia
nachdem auch die
meinungsäußerung und auch die freiheit
der kunst beschränkt ist also es gibt
verschiedene grenzen der meinungs- und
kunstfreiheit ist jetzt natürlich nur
juristisch und moralisch wir wollen ja
hier von einem moralischen perspektiven
drüber reden und diese grenzen werden
juristisch anders ausgelegt zum beispiel
den usa werden gewaltdarstellungen meist
unkritischer bewährte pornografie
hingegen viel strenger das sieht
natürlich auch in computerspielen also
wolfenstein 3d waren den usa nicht
indiziert ist ein sehr gewalttätige
spielfeld damaligen zeit gewesen in
deutschland war es indiziert das sind
jetzt natürlich nur juristische fragen
die nicht die moral betreffen so jetzt
müssen wir also auf die frage eingehen
worin besteht der ethische unterschied
zwischen
computerspielen und
anderen medien in einem buch werden
moralisch problematische passagen
erzählt beziehungsweise fungiert sie
werden vor unserem geistigen auge
ja entstehen wir sind daran beteiligt
sie zu konstruieren und unsere phantasie
wird angeregt aber sie wird angeregt auf
basis des jähnigen was da steht mit
buchen es gibt den fall dass auch bücher
indiziert wurden weil sie extrem
problematisch waren können sie alles
nachlesen auf wikipedia ein weiteres
punkt ein weiterer punkt gibt gibt es
sehr dass in einem film moralisch
problematische passagen gespielt werde
auch regiert werden es wurden auch filme
indiziert weise gewalt verherrlichen und
zutaten waren vielleicht auch menschen
fahren jetzt nehme aber dieses beispiel
ein computerspiel werden moralisch
problematische passagen selbst gespielt
bzw
simuliert sie sehen einen unterschied in
büchern und filmen wird ihm das
vorgespielt das wird ihnen präsentiert
im computerspiel wird es ihn auch
teilweise präsentiert das setting aber
sie können es selbst noch vollzieht wir
können entscheidend wie sie diese gewalt
simulieren wie sie die gewalt und
computerspiel durchführen und das geht
in konkurs geht in filmen und romanen
nicht und da sehen sie es gibt eben doch
ein unterschied gibt dadurch dass sie
selbst involviert sind werden auch nur
im rahmen dieser simulation
und jetzt können uns sagen welches moral
philosophische paradigma eignet sich am
besten und computerspiele ethisch zu
bewerten
wir können's frage wird die würde der
spielenden person oder anderen person
dadurch verletzt dass die theologie
denkt sie an immanuel kant die
kategorische imperativ
lassen sich die motive im computerspiel
vernünftig für allgemeinen die maximen
es sind die intrinsische schlecht oder
gut die motive das ist ja das worum es
bei der d & o logi geht der konsequenz
allis muss sind die konsequenzen des
computerspielens für die spiele die
person und die anderen person schlecht
sicherlich nicht für die simulierte
person da gibt es ja keine konsequenzen
die tu genetik verschlechtert sich der
moralische charakter des spielenden
personen durch das computerspiel das
sind jetzt zu drei mögliche paradigmen
mit denen wird dieses was ich da
vollzieht im simulation in der aktiven
simulation bewerten können wir auf die
technologie an wir können uns fragen was
für gründe sollte ein computerspieler
eine computerspielen haben menschen auf
möglichst detaillierte simulierte weise
grausam zu töten und ich denke schon
dass man hier wenn man jetzt auf das
motiv eingeht dass problematisieren kann
warum denn was für einen grund sollte
ein mensch haben das zu tun da stecken
vielleicht menschen hasst dahinter was
auch immer ich denke dass man aus seiner
theologie und theologische perspektive
ein solches computerspiel videos und
jetzt vorgestellt haben eine hochgradig
realistische menschen tötungs simulation
dass man die aus theologischer hinsicht
durchaus problematisieren kann die man
sich fragt was sind dafür motive
dahinter
natürlich muss man immer schauen auf die
einzel motiv es könnte auch sein eine
person möchte einfach mal das
ausprobieren und das mal erkunden dann
ist die frage wie ist es dann zu
bewerten darüber müssen wir diskutieren
wir müssen hier nach der theologie auf
das motiv schauen es lässt sich aber nur
schwer vorstellen dass nicht ein gutes
motiv hinter einer solchen
simulierten tötung von unschuldigen
personen viertel ich kann mir kein
moralisch gutes motiv prima fazit
vorstellen konsequenz iannis muss sind
die konsequenzen des computerspiels für
die spiele personen andere personen
schlecht ja
gibt es verschiedene psychologische
theorien da gibt es verschiedene studien
manche sagen gewalt computerspiele ego
shooter sind nicht dafür verantwortlich
dass die person gewalttätige wird da gab
es eine riesen debatte bei jedem
amoklauf entsteht diese debatte neu ich
selbst bin kein psychologe so dass ich
dazu nicht sagen kann will sie können
darüber googeln es gibt verschiedene
studien darüber
man könnte aber sich sicherlich wie im
sinne des degi und theologie belegen
welche motive liegen hier zugrunde und
werden diese motive verstärkt wenn sie
moralisch problematisch denn ich glaube
schon also wer eben sich in einer
simulation flüchtet und dort seien
fantasie nachgeht die darauf abzielen
unschuldige menschen zu töten
für den sind die konsequenzen sicherlich
nicht besonders gut weil er sich in
einer scheinwelt flüchtet und dort
gewisse aggression die er oder sie hat
auf eine weise auslebt die natürlich
immer noch simuliert ist aber die doch
irgendwie eine spannung zur wirklichkeit
steht ich glaube nicht dass das gut ist
zumindest für die spiele person für
andere personen zunächst einmal nicht
andere personen sind damit nicht
involviert es seitens geht und
computerspiele mit mehreren spielerinnen
und spielern online computerspiel und
darin finden diese simulation statt dann
wird das noch mal viel komplizierter und
zuletzt zu genetik das hängt damit auch
zusammen wenn natürlich gewisse motive
die moralisch problematisch sind wie
menschen hast oder sowas wenn die im
computerspielen verstärkt werden dann
wird sich das sicherlich problematisch
auf den charakter auswirkt auch wenn es
nur eine simulation ist er hat die
intention die absicht ist ja ganz klar
sichtbar aber es kommt immer von den
hängen ganz klar von den motiven was da
eine frau die da eine rolle spielen ja
jetzt kann man abschließend sagen
computerspiele
gelten nicht mehr nur als zeitvertreib
und nutzlose spieler reißen werden immer
mehr als ästhetisch als auch was die
schönheit partie ja das spiel anbelangt
und philosophisch interessante phänomene
ernst genommen
computerspiele sind nicht nur
spielereien und konsumieren das
handelsgeschehen computerspiele sind
vielmehr experimentierfelder auf den
spielerisch die verhältnis von realität
simulation fiktion und illusion erprobt
werden deswegen kann man computerspiele
auch alles eine art von lebensform zu
stehen
computerspiele sind eine form von
philosophie würde ich jetzt hier
behaupten weil in ihnen das problem
virtuelle realität spielerisch
verhandelt wird alles geht um die frage
wie verhält sich die wirklichkeit zu den
inhalten computerspiel im computer
spielen es ist ja auch eine aktivität
das computerspielen und nicht nur die
passiven rezeptions haltung da stellen
wir selbst komplexe wirklichkeit
verhältnissen die wir mit diesen
modalitäten möglichkeit wirklichkeit
illusion fiktion simulation spielen
es heißt wir loten darin die
ontologischen grenzen von wirklichkeit
illusionen simulationen fiktion aus
spieler
und wir loten natürlich dadurch auch die
moralischen grenzen von wirklichkeit
lustig simulation fiktion aus wir können
computerspiel ghetto in der die wir in
der wirklichkeit so nicht machen können
vielleicht können uns aber nicht
getrauen das heißt es findet ihr auch
ein neuer kunde und des moralischen
möglichkeitsraum ist stadt und die frage
nach der moralischen bewertung ist eben
ganz schwierig weil es ihnen nicht die
wirklichkeit ist ja das war es für die
heutige sitzung in der nächsten sitzung
behandelte thema was mit dem computer
spielen doch irgendwie auch zu tun hat
wenn es zumindest um gewalt
verherrlichende brutale simulation geht
nämlich das digitale böse hierbei spielt
jetzt aber nicht nur das computerspiel
eine rolle sondern auch fragen nach
künstlicher intelligenz ihrem einsatz
fragen nach robotik fragen nach porz
nach spam nach anderen neuen formen muss
man sich fragen des bösen die vielleicht
auch im internet durch kunst intelligenz
realisiert werden können diese fragen
soll in der nächsten sitzung im zentrum
stehen dann bedanke ich mich vielmals
für die aufmerksamkeit gerne kann man
immer alles unten mitdiskutieren auf
youtube und bis zur nächsten sitzung